اذا المياه مقطوعه وانت وفرت فهي ملوثه
واحياء سكنيه تحولت الى منطقه اشباح موحشه
يخيم عليها الخراب والموت هذا مشاهدينا
بعض ما تواجهه مدينه الخرطوم بحري التي
يقطنها مليونان اسمه تقريبا بعد شهر من
الاقتتال العسكري بين طرفي النزاع الكارثه
في المدينه كبيره جدا حتى دفن الموتى اصبح
مهمه عسيره وشاقه وهنا تخوف كبير من
انتشار طبعا الامراض والاوبئه بعد تحلل
هذه الجثث في الطرقات المدينه التي تمثل
الضلع الثالث للعاصمه المثلثه تواجه ايضا
شحف الوقود وانقطاع الكهرباء والاتصالات
بعدما تاثرت شبكات الاتصال وابراج
التقنيات لانقطاع التيار الكهربائي جراء
طبعا القصف المتبادل والعشوائي بين طرفي
الصراع هذا المشهد مشاهدينا حول بحري الى
منطقه كوارث خاصه بعد تدهور الاوضاع
الامنيه وانتشار عصابات السلب والسرقه هذا
كان ميدانيا اما سياسيا جمد رئيس مجلس
السياده الانتقاليه عبد الفتاح البرهان
حسابات قوات الدعم السريع وشركاتها في
جميع البنوك في السودان وفروعها في الخارج
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات